After a crazy work week in New York,
we finally made it to Utah for a few days
to hang out with some family and friends,
and we obviously had to stop by Hannah's house for some brunch.
We had a whole spread going on with some croissants, crepes, fruits,
homemade Nutella, and jams.
Daniel also made us some yogurt the night before,
which I couldn't get enough of.
Kids could not contain their excitement
and started running around the property while we had some brunch.
Then it was time to head over to see the dairy.
Getting 11 kids ready and out of the house took a second,
but we finally made it onto our little walk,
and the kids bonded over finding some tiny snakes
before we made it over to the dairy barn.
Seeing all the cows and the animals made me want a cow,
even though I don't think I could ever manage that.
The kids were so fascinated,
and when we got back to the house wanted some milk immediately.
Alex also made us some homemade ice cream,
which was delicious. It was nice for all of us to sit down and catch up
and talk about everything that's been going on.
Rumble and slim needed to see how a cow was milked,
so I gave it a try, and it's a lot harder than Hannah makes it look.
We were all so sad to leave,
but we know we're gonna be back very soon.